wie H es könen passieren D wir nie
überle was das SP für Konsequenz Kön die
das
Kind so drun
[Musik]
das auf Social Media
ze PR Kind das stimmt nicht ganz ichig
has
K das stört mir das macht mich hastig
das ist das Verstand so als ältere du
Set sie einfach in wo du keine ah das
kann passieren wenn man Fotos voning
postet und wel R spielt die künstliche
Intelligenz
ne was ich immer wieder für Kinder auf
Social Media da gehing im Bikini
strandfing der Windler
irgendwcheing lustigeö und Jes mal Frage
Leute
warum auf die Idee dass sie fing hey das
ist die beste Option das oder
das ganze
zeig K Videos online ST und aber Social
Media Konsum ganz vi ke Grenze oder
ganzere
Grenze Kass auf tiktok
begeignet du
bist wie
[Musik]
bitte das
wor
okay was heißt das
eigentlich ja also ich libe ja Fußball
und sag m Liebe
Fußball Millionen
l und ger Interview mit dir gemacht und
hat Frage hey was ist die Motivation wie
Gefüh D das okay ist das machen s ABEs
mit der begründig sie ihr Sohn
Schütze lustig im sin d so Schütze
eigent super F ichber W mit vi mal ke se
jokes me mit V Millionen Publikum ma Z
ja der originalvion auf
tiktoking erkennbar ist
ja Thema irgendwie triggert und drum
Report wieso gbt Elter wo das völlig
okay fen Content
V Blase undo ma und geht es richtig und
fsch aufg zu Claudia sie mit ihr Tochter
auf insta undrecht das Millionen
Publikum
oh mein
[Musik]
Gott so bin wieder Claudia und ich B
sehr gespannt sie eigentlich die
kräisste Form vom kinderzeigemcht nlich
aus M fluenzerin verdient sie no gut mit
und sind sie Argument
s hello
[Musik]
halloaudia Videos wo me aus
Million sogar über 1
Million
mit
Tochter bist nur
ma aber Videos ziemlich krass Kommentar
Tochter kommentier kom
Norm mach
mit das
Öffentlichkeit
also ist schon mal ich schon schnufe
aber K und weiß nicht 24 Stunden so sind
und ich wei die vol dem autonome Phas
ist es für mich wirklich nein es trifft
mich in de sin aber klar ich schon m
überlegen was lauft jetzt da was was was
ist falsch warte
stopin
warte das
bra
[Musik]
mus das
bra sehr stressig und
W mit
Kommentar dasig für
m vi Schü V
dem der Kommentar vor der beurteilig V
de
Kommentar sie h i Art impulsive
lebendige Art und sobald mir Hus verlönt
ist sie ja nicht anders und so Blick so
Komment gibt natürlich auch TSE wenn wir
irgendwo sind also wenn man ein
Restaurant gönt es l alle blöd oder geh
Kauf supermkt supermkt K oder die W ganz
genau jetzt git Chus da
also ich schütze sie dem S dann müsste
ich sie
fast sie h ihre
Art das kann ich nicht änder ich sie
Begleit und sie s helffe muss es
öffentlich sie
das kommentier
und ich glaube das muss öffentlich es
muss nicht ich glaube aber dass ist ganz
ganz viel Mam h das sieh sie sind nicht
allein das sind hunderte vono ich von M
bedankt sieint Kind sie nur so sie auch
sie nirgends willkommen sind Kinder
lebendig sind und ich glaub das muss sie
ja ich bin bereit das alles in Kauf D
andere Mamis sich nicht allein F ja du
bist bereit
aber
sie ist sch ein Teil von dem ganzen sie
ist ja das ist ja ihre Art ih ih ihre
Persönlichkeit und ich unterstütze Sie
sie DF so sie wie sie ist und mir wen
das nicht verstecke ich will sie nicht
verstecken wie sie lebendig und
willenstark ist sie ist nicht anders wie
andere Kinder nur dass mir das halt so
zeiget und be insta ist klar zeigt man
die Kind nicht so es ist so eine K inst
oder und doch ich
glaube man ja ist nicht sie sie ist
glücklich sie macht das gern natürlich
wenn sie meh Verst um was es geht dann K
immer noch anders reagier oder anders
machen aber jetzt denke so Familie das
was mir W message W W doch ich glaube
ist okay gut ja das stimmt wenigstens
authentisch Realität wie mit und wenn
sie
sout machen
ja muss sch sagen der Kinder Content ist
für sie ein Business und das W immer
wieder
vorf will nur Geld ver ja und warum
nicht was ist denn
Feld wie vi verdien
es kommt sch auf der follow und
R der
jetzig
follow sch ab 500 fr
aufw mit große Firma schaffen ja das
mach minut und bis zu
Stories gr
was ich nicht zeig was es gibtmer Kinder
ke privatsph oder kinderh kein und das
stimmt nicht ganz ich zeig ja
hauptsächlich Kind in der K Grenz sind
bei mir ganz klar Schlafzimmer das ist
Privatsphäre das ist wo sie Schlaf das
ist d wo sie sich was sie a sich
zurückziehen und so
wiiter ganz ganz Kleid Badwanne
oder mit der Wind so Sachen das sind für
mich
ein nicht zeig ja
das was wird sie Post und
was ja das W ich ja spielt
Badminton
ja das W ich weniger das ist Situation
wo ich als Mam möchte
trö W nicht
war die POS was will ich meine Follower
damit zeigen nein da schalte Handy ab
und du
trö ja natürlich wasserpitze warum nicht
kindheitserinner ja das W ich nein das
Gott gar nicht nein das
[Musik]
das wer got nicht ferie W got nicht
ferie und zeigt sich als
Familie kein Bloger ist oder wer Gott
nicht das Familie ferie und zeigt Bilder
von Kinder am Strand der ganze
Familie jetzt so das so würde ich nicht
ich kaufe
generellleid ich auch so Bilder wo wir
am Strand sind mit
ihre ja vielleicht wenn sie älter ist
würde ich jetzt so nicht posten ja aber
ist fr was zeigen wir Familie oder
Freunde zeig ber der sind oder aber
jetzt ab das sie beste wor für Töchter
was unsicher B ist wirklich abschätze
wie das die AR wenn sie te wenn sie
wachsen ist wenn da xfach Content V ih
im Net existiert wo
millionenfacht wordde
das ja das passt sch für Dasing denn das
ist das
schig jetzt
mus jetzt interessiert mich die and
wieso Po gar keine
Kinder und dem pasale
abgemacht zu dem
themaing
K
online Argument ist künstliche
Intelligenz
pasale K pasale schon länger
geschafft Content Creator steht für
diverse Social Media Kampagne vor der
Kamera also das
ist und ich meine Sachen aufnehm
für ganz viel verschiedene Kunde jedes
mal wenn du sportch der pasber auf
Social Media aktiv
ziemlich aber auf tiktok
inst jy oder
Jogging gerade richtig
perfekt ja das ist also das hat der
ganze einfache Grund das ist wenn du auf
M Kanal KST dann KST du für mich und
nicht für meine
Kinder von sag ja aber das ist Teil von
M le W ich
gern schüz ja aber ich frage mich das
mit mir Situation verglich der pasale
Online ziemlich Publikum auf insta s
über 26000 Follower in und auf tiktok
12000 W
du ze wenn du normale
R nein also d k grü wo jetzt der Rolle
Spiel aber d ums mehr Z BR von
Frau mit ihn Spiel in also meine Frau
schaff in der
Justiz und ist sowieso kein Thema das
irgendwie
vor allem Kinder erkennbar sind mit
ihrem
Job und auch bchen Job will ich sehe
halt die künstliche
Intelligenz also das Level wo man
momentan sind ist wirklich beangstigend
also ich meine alle die creators die
können
dir schaffe tagtäglich mit kün
Intelligenz und die können dir Sache
machen das ist beangstigen du denkst du
nein das geht's nicht das W was was kann
man machen was was
lurfahren letzte Woche hte Lars eine wo
schafft Creator h m stimm
Genom und dann hat mir SPR geschickt wen
ich auf tamilis irgende sait und zwar
min also ist
wirklich also mit dir stimmt mit mir
stimm genau und aber geschrieben was was
ich soll sagen und so und es ist
so so gut al es ist so mit mit richtigge
apruch und einfach Mini stim aufil alles
kann sag das ist NIS klein das kann
schnell kurze zitrum machen aber du
kannst mit Bilder mit mit Videos kannst
den Sache machen wenn
duch du schickst das
we wie es braucht wird und vor allem wie
es missbucht wird das
ist ja okay merke Kare Linie drum
NZ nein das W nicht Post einfach
zuerkennar Kind
inere nicht mega
n so nicht so gut nächste Bild auf gar
kein Fall würde ich das
Post wenn du mir Geld g so eine intime
Szene V von me Kind wo
man nein
[Musik]
das
schwierig
W du wirklich nicht erkennbar W jetzt
nicht mal könen sagen ob
glaub aber auch da ist schwierig das ist
wird Po will nicht wir kein Grund
se nie das nie nie im Le vor allem also
jetzt als Vater se irendwi dass es gar
kein aufsätzer h das ist sowieso mega
unnatürlich ab nicht authentisch W
das
ich habe keine mE aber das würde
never nie im Le also
nein
und ja das stört mir wenn ich so Bilder
se das ist
wirklich wenn das mE irgendwie 18 oder
20 und
dann findet dass Mami und der Papi das
postet haben und L das gleich und
theoretisch auf fremde Menschen das
gleich hab und mit D können nein also
das sch ich Teil unde Bilder was macht
mit dir das stört mir es macht mich
hassig es macht mirich hassig vor allem
für Kinder will die können wie nicht
Schütze also du bist das ist das ist das
ich nicht verstand so als ältere du bist
wie du bist verantwortlich für die
kleine menschlich und du setz sie
einfach in wo du keine mus wirklich von
D man meint es se nur die L was du
meinst dir s also komm das ist komplett
falsch also seh auf fremde und wenn du
dich für das Entscheid ich dann muss du
das einfach bewusst se will immer Kinder
so in schön l Dru s ich bestte Kinder le
meine Kinder bitte das ist genau das ist
aber nicht fürs Kind das ist für dich
wenn du ganz ehrlich bist NZ du
eigentlich das für die
[Musik]
überleg malwer machen
wenn
und
das das Video das das theoretisch und
das wird das wird
ab ganz ehrlich
[Musik]
fragt
machen KI künstlich Intelligenz ist
schon noch gegang der Aspekt da h die D
Telekom so eine Kampagne
[Musik]
gemacht da geht um Spar wo kinderöter
oder Tochter online
poste und n schient die in im
[Musik]
Kino hey mom hey Dad ich bin Ella na ja
eine digitale Version von mir nur etwas
älter erstaunlich was he alles kann oder
alles was man braucht sind ein paar
Bilder sowie die die ihr auf Social
Media teilt wo jeder sie nehmen
nutzen und missbrauchen
kann ich weiß für euch sind diese Bilder
nur Erinnerungen aber für andere sind
sie Daten und für mich vielleicht der
Anfang einer schrecklichen
Zukunft ich werde zum zum meme
gedemütigt von allen in der Schule bring
dich um du verfickter
Loser und am wenigsten will
ich
das was ihr online teilt ist ein
digitaler Fußabdruck der mich verfolgen
wird für den Rest meines Lebens okay es
ist ziemlich dramatisch aufgemacht aber
so Grundbotschaft fin ich verständlich
mit künst inelligenz ist einiges möglich
mit der V wo vielleicht du voning online
[Musik]
stell V Weg zur Barbara und se h nochere
Sicht wie auf das ganze s frü ziemlich
viel V V postet
und und spannend Interview ist Sohn
Paulo wie also erst direkt
[Musik]
betroffenft
läer
Spielgruppe
befundet und die merke Paulo
[Gelächter]
KIG
wirfang also 15 jahfangen mit Facebook
mit diesem familienacc Account
undang
Kinder eh und später auch Ella zeige
also so wiees Album wo man macht für
Familie hab wir einfach alle die schöne
Momente hab wir postet ja und was ist
für Impuls oder was für gedan gemacht
gedankke nicht viel drüber gemacht der
Impuls ist GH dass stolz ist dass
wir ja Mama ist und D mit die
Momente mit all möcht wie teil Freunde
im Ausland und die
teem stolz Kind undem Alltag und da ja
hemmiglos postet was h es für Folge
Folge sind erst wo Kind größer worden
sind wo ihres Umfeld auch auf Social
Media unterwegs
ist ist s Word sie sind zum Teil Sch
acht wurde die sind ein
klassat wo wo man einfach so lcherlich
gacht hat
und ja drun
und Gefühl D es nicht okay ist wenn man
sie einfach postet und Frage postet
Barbara und
n und wenn den frag da s die letzte Foto
und hier
na langsam hier jetzt be Z wenn ich draf
B der ist es wenn ich überhaupt noch
drauf B jetzt bin ich hier auf ganz vi
drauf das hier bin ich Tru das ist aber
das mfragt hat mir total n und hier GH
mal wir fast n
Tru und hier b d hier bin
Verstand mit Papa und sch bin ich
eigentlich
genau das früher unbremst Kinder Post F
Paulo gar nicht gut bei mir ist ist zum
Glück nie wirk so mobbing inflossen kann
aber gut vorstellen dass es wirklich so
schlimmer D mobing be mir aber immer so
einfach de
lächerlich
al so aber das ist nicht toll toll und
sie zum teilfoto zugeschickt wurde so ja
l was die Vater oder die Mama od was dir
postety und so und das ist ja nie
wirklich schön g
also auf jeden Fall ja also
nim so freizügig Sache
POS al wenn jetzt die Frage ganz ehrlich
beantwortet zum Teil sch ja es gibt
mehrlich Sache da n me
und da gibt nch andere Sachen wo
vielleicht l einfach übert da und das mE
weniger aber
zum was macht das mit dir
Barbara das tut mir wirklich leid
und ich würde es wie gern rückgangig
machen aber das das kan wir leider n
und es es geht mir n und und und ich
frage mich immer wie hät es passier D
nie überle was das SP für Konsequenz die
also wie im gut gemacht und das Kind
n so drun li das hat ich denkt n so
machen Kinder onlineöcht jetzt
non sie w Post
[Musik]
das ja
rum
[Musik]
so ne ne das
klassenat genau wenn man so gr ja genau
das würde das find ich okay das
W ne ne ne ne ne ne das ist das F
Mobbing ja definitiv
ja das das W nicht als Mama
[Musik]
freizigit super Paulo
reportig was
es Social Media Lande füring ist einfach
plich sehr penlich und
drum
[Musik]
ja schön zum Abschluss noch re
mir social
mediaangfage geht es richtig oder de
Thema und glau
für sich selberingen was für richtig ist
sag jetzt im Rahmen von der Reportage g
und gehört
bestärkt wihin ke Bilder voning online
zeigen dass es in spter mega plich ist
oder noch schlimmer D spter inht
werde einfach nicht was ist
Meining online ze oder nicht me
interessiert mich
hier Kommentar
undf reagieren und F fing auf
Play